Sollen wir nach vorne laufen
und nach dem Gleis schauen oder ...
Wir laufen einfach mal.
Ist das der Zug nach Berlin?
Wir suchen den Wagen 302.
Ich folge dir.
(Durchsage) Welcome on board
at Zurich Mainstation.
Wo ist das Bett?
- Hinter mir.
Hier ist es.
* Sanfte Soulballade "Across
110th Street" von Bobby Womack *
Hier oben zieht es an die Füsse.
- Wirklich?
# Doing whatever I had to do
to survive.
# I'm not saying what I did
was alright.
Ich heisse Jonas. Ich bin 26
und arbeite als Sachbearbeiter
beim Eidg. Hochschulinstitut
für Berufsbildung.
Seit meinem sechsten Lebensjahr
sehe ich nichts mehr.
Weil ich früher einmal gesehen habe,
erinnere ich mich gut an Farben.
# ... until you're put
under pressure.
# Across 110th Street
is a hell of a tester.
# Across 110th Street.
Ich heisse Yves, bin 31
und komme aus dem Kanton Fribourg.
Von Beruf bin ich Radiomacher.
Schon seit meiner Geburt
sehe ich 2 %.
Ich sehe auch Farben und
für mich sind die Dinge auch scharf.
Verglichen mit jemandem, der
gut sieht, wäre es wohl unscharf.
* Sanfte Soulballade "Across
110th Street" von Bobby Womack *
# Across 110th Street.
Wir haben dem Fernsehen
die Sendung vorgeschlagen,
weil wir v.a.
dank zwei Dingen reisen können.
Dank der Technik und den Begegnun-
gen - Menschen, die uns helfen.
Wir wollten unbedingt zeigen,
wie wichtig es ist,
dass man einander hilft,
dass man etwas zeigt
und dass man miteinander redet.
Durch Begegnungen
kann man Grosses entstehen lassen.
Weisst du, wohin wir nun müssen?
Wir werden auf unseren Reisen
oft damit konfrontiert,
warum wir als Blinde oder
Sehbehinderte überhaupt reisen.
Die Leute denken,
wir hätten nichts davon.
Dabei können wir
die Stadt auch erleben.
Über Gerüche,
über Leute, die wir kennenlernen.
Das möchten wir unbedingt
weitergeben und zeigen,
dass Reisen
auch als Sehbehinderter Spass macht.
# In every city you find
the same thing going down.
# Harlem is the capital
of every ghetto town.
# Across 110th Street.
Dank den anderen Sinnen und den
Begegnungen habe ich oft das Gefühl,
dass wir beim Reisen
beinahe mehr sehen als Sehende.
Fahrräder!
* Sanfte Soulballade "Across
110th Street" von Bobby Womack *
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Es brennt, obwohl ...
Es brennt wieder.
Es brennt noch einen Moment
ohne Karte und hört dann auf.
Okay.
Gehen wir?
- Ja.
Hast du den Rucksack?
- Nein. Hast du eine Tasche?
Wohin tust du dein T-Shirt?
- Kann ich es dir geben?
Das ist noch nicht gesagt.
- Warum? - Ich überlege noch.
Sagt dein Navi etwas?
Ja, wir sind um 9.17 Uhr da.
Wollen wir nach rechts gehen?
Komm, wir gehen mal ... Wobei ...
Ich weiss nicht,
ob es hier richtig ist.
Wir gehen nach vorne.
Links abbiegen.
Gehen wir hier?
Über die Strasse.
Oh, Achtung! Fahrräder!
Hatte es hier kein Lichtsignal?
Vielleicht schaute ich zu wenig gut,
aber es war eine kleine Strasse.
Wir wollen nach Berlin, weil es
eine Stadt ist, die momentan boomt.
Ich möchte wissen,
wie die Grossstadt ist,
denn es ist eine Grossstadt.
Was heisst das? Wie spüren wir das?
Ich freue mich auch
auf das Kulinarische.
Einerseits auf die deutsche Küche,
aber auch auf die Currywurst.
Der Boden ist nicht flach.
Fahrräder links.
Bei der Einfahrt
hat es einen Pfosten.
Ich freue mich, in Berlin auch
geschichtliche Dinge zu entdecken.
Die Berliner Mauer
interessiert mich sehr.
Wie sehr prägt sie die Menschen
auch heute noch?
Hier leben so viele verschiedene
Leute zusammen, auf kleinem Raum,
wenn man das so sagen kann.
Sind die Leute toleranter?
Fällt man weniger auf,
wenn man eine Behinderung hat?
Oh, Achtung! - Das war
denkbar ungünstig. - Jetzt! - Ja.
* Dynamische Musik,
Klacken des Blindenstocks *
Das muss deine Brücke sein.
- Ja, ja.
Oh, jetzt wird es gut.
Wie sieht die Distanz aus?
- 80 m.
Gleich müssen wir rechts abbiegen.
Ja, komm! Entlang dieser Maschine.
Die hört jeder!
- Selbst ein TV-Journalist.
* Das Rattern der Maschine
übertönt das Gesprochene. *
Guten Morgen, Herr Arnold.
Hier ist Yves Kilchör.
Wir befinden uns
in der Nähe einer Maschine.
Ich weiss nicht, ob Sie uns sehen.
Yves?
- Super, vielen Dank!
Vielleicht sind wir zu spät.
(Alle) Guten Morgen!
Mit wem habe ich telefoniert?
Hallo, guten Morgen!
- Ich bin Adrian.
Freut mich, Yves. - Wir duzen
einander, das ist einfacher.
Hallo, Adrian.
- Jonas, freut mich.
Freut mich sehr.
Schön, dass ihr in Berlin seid.
Wir beobachten beide,
was auf der Welt alles passiert.
Deutschland spielt eine grosse
Rolle, bei allen möglichen Themen.
Eine wichtige Rolle spielt dabei
auch der Fernsehkorrespondent.
Wie ordnet er die Situation ein?
Und er äussert sich
zur ganzen Geschichte.
Darf ich mich bei dir anhängen?
- Ja, natürlich.
Wir haben ihn getroffen,
weil wir dachten,
dass er uns ein Berlin zeigen kann,
wie kaum jemand anderes.
Die Distanz zwischen dem Kanzleramt
von Frau Merkel
und der Schweizer Botschaft
beträgt etwa 50 m.
Okay.
Eine breite Strasse
liegt dazwischen.
Der Schweizer Botschafter
oder die Schweizer Botschafterin -
aktuell ist es ein Botschafter -
kann Frau Merkel ins Büro schauen.
Links oben
ist das Büro von Frau Merkel.
Bist du dort schon gewesen?
- In ihrem Büro nicht.
Aber im Kanzleramt,
im Gebäude selbst, sind wir oft.
Dort finden
die Pressekonferenzen statt.
Letzthin war Frankreichs Präsident
Emmanuel Macron hier.
Er fuhr von rechts kommend her,
mit Auto, Polizei, Motorrad etc.
Dann hat sie ihn empfangen.
Zuerst gibt es immer
einen Handshake.
Für einen Beitrag
ist es oft auch sehr wichtig,
dass man die Mimik beobachtet.
Frau Merkel hat eine verschmitzte,
sanfte, Mimik.
Man merkt, dass sie ab und zu auch
nach aussen ein Signal geben will.
* Lachen *
Spannend, dass er das
mit der Mimik erwähnt hat.
Das scheint recht wichtig zu sein.
Als sehende Person versucht man,
viel darin zu interpretieren.
"Was war mit diesem
oder jenem gemeint?"
Das machen wir auch -
mit der Stimme.
Wenn ich eine Stimme höre,
dann denke ich,
dass die Person traurig
oder eher glücklich klingt.
Die Mimik ist sicher etwas,
was uns halt fehlt.
Könnt ihr euch das vorstellen,
wie das Gebäude aussieht?
(Beide) Ja.
* Viele Stimmen durcheinander. *
Der Reichstag ist,
ich würde mal sagen,
etwa drei- bis viermal so gross
wie das Bundeshaus in Bern.
Ah, ja. So gross?
Ich stelle ihn mir
wie die Akropolis vor.
Da gibt es auch dieses Dreieck.
- Genau.
Man kann es tatsächlich vergleichen.
Eine gewisse Ähnlichkeit ist da.
Das hier ist relativ neu.
Hier oben sind die alten Mauern.
Ah, ja. Es ist
ein grosser Unterschied.
So fühlt sich deutsche Politik an.
Hart. - Knallhart.
- Rauh und steinig. - Genau.
Siehst du, ich habe sie
auch noch nie angefasst.
Den Sandstein spürt ihr sofort.
- Mhm.
Wie in Bern im Münster.
- Ja, genau.
Oder?
- Ich würde es schon sagen.
An einigen Stellen
hat es auch noch Einschusslöcher
aus dem Zweiten Weltkrieg.
- Ah, sicher? - Wirklich?
- Ja.
Es war eine super Idee von Adrian,
dass er uns diese Mauer zeigte
und wir sie spüren konnten.
Auch die Erklärung dazu, dass sie
den Zweiten Weltkrieg überlebte.
Das wird in Erinnerung bleiben.
Man hat auch das Gefühl
von diesem Reichstag in Erinnerung.
Ich zeige euch
die "Aufsagerposition",
den Ort der Liveschaltungen.
Warst du gestern dort?
Ja, gestern war ich auch dort.
Das ist auch ein Grund,
warum wir reisen:
Dass man das, was wir
in der "Tagesschau" hören -
wir hören sie ja meistens -
auch spüren oder riechen kann.
Erlebt.
Es wird dann für euch
dreidimensional.
Ja, genau.
* Dynamische Musik *
Und du stehst dann ...
Genau, ich stehe eigentlich
mit dem Rücken zum Reichstag,
so wie ihr jetzt steht.
Da vorne steht der Kameramann
und er filmt in meine Richtung -
oder dir jetzt ins Gesicht -
und hinten sieht man schön
den Reichstag
Gut, wir machen mal eine Frage.
Eine kurze Einschätzung:
Deutschland -
im Vergleich zur Schweiz.
Wie sind die ersten Eindrücke
aus Berlin?
Ich muss warten. Es gibt immer
eine Verzögerung, bis du sprichst.
* Lachen *
Genau.
Die Deutschen sind sicher direkter,
das haben wir schon gemerkt.
Uns gefallen v.a. auch
die Schweizer in Berlin sehr gut.
Besser hättest du das
nicht sagen können!
* Lachen *
* Dynamische Musik *
Wir gehen auf diese Seite.
Da oben ist mein Coiffeur.
Du bist ja bekannt für deine Frisur.
(Lachend) Man sagt es.
Wie hast du ihn gefunden?
Er befindet sich in meinem Quartier.
* Schwungvolle Musik *
Ich hatte das Gefühl,
dass Adrian von Anfang an checkte,
was wir wollen.
Das habe ich cool gefunden.
Er hat uns sein Berlin gezeigt.
Sehr schön, vielen Dank.
Er war die beste Art
von Reiseführer.
Jonas,
noch etwas mehr zur Mitte hin.
Für die Sehenden ist es wichtig,
nicht nur uns zuzuhören,
sondern auch,
wie es dort ausgesehen hat.
Meine Mutter ist ein grosser Fan
von Adrian Arnold.
Ohne Foto hätte ich mich
kaum nach Hause gewagt.
Voila.
- Super! - Danke.
* Rhythmische Musik *
Wollt ihr zur U-Bahn?
- Ja, genau. - Genau.
Ich geh mit euch mit.
- Ah, super!
Darf ich mich halten?
- Ja, klar. Wollt ihr beide?
Geht das? - Ja, klar.
- Danke!
Wo wollt ihr denn hin?
Zu Curry 36 an der ...
- Oh, natürlich!
Kennen Sie es?
Jetzt, los!
Ja, Curry 36 kenne ich.
Hier seid ihr bei Burgermeister -
der ist auch sehr lecker.
Was sollen wir eher nehmen?
Also die Warteschlange
ist sehr, sehr lange.
Das dauert mind. 1 Std.
Kommt man grundsätzlich
mit Menschen in Kontakt,
bekommt man verschiedene Dinge
von ihnen mit.
Hängt man ihnen am Arm ein,
spürt man die Haut.
Oder man riecht vielleicht
ihren Geruch, ihr Parfum.
So macht man sich ein Bild.
So mache ich mir
ein Bild von Frauen.
Kommen Sie aus Kreuzberg?
Ich komme aus Rostock, lebe in
Dänemark und lebte lange in Berlin.
Ich glaube,
Sie war etwas kleiner als ich.
sie war nicht mega schlank.
Ihre Haut war nicht so zart.
Ähm.
Sie war sehr freundlich.
Soll ich mit euch reingehen?
Haben Sie noch Zeit?
- Ja, klar.
Jemanden sehen und dann, wow,
das ist eine hübsche, sympathische
Frau, die möchte ich kennenlernen.
Diesen Moment haben wir halt nicht.
Bei Frauen
fragt man wohl eher mal nach,
ob man sie beschreiben kann.
Oder, ähm ...
Über das Gespräch, die Einstellung,
den Humor ...
Über die Art, wie eine Frau spricht,
was sie erzählt,
wie sich für einen interessiert.
Die Einschätzung,
was sie von einem will oder denkt,
finde ich extrem schwierig.
Findet man eine Frau
vom Charakter her schön,
ist sie automatisch auch vom Aus-
sehen her schön, für mich zumindest.
* Alle reden durcheinander. *
Vier Stufen und dann nach rechts.
- Super, vielen Dank!
Schönen Tag! - Danke!
- Super, danke!
Hier!
- Nein, nein, nein!
Weiter!
- Ah, sie sagte ja weiter.
Oh, Entschuldigung!
Ist hier Curry 36?
- Das ist Curry 36.
Müssen wir hier anstehen?
Ja, genau so.
Ist die Schlange lang?
- Nein.
(Frau) Für Curry 36 geht's.
- Okay.
Man ist sich ja da nicht so sicher,
ob die Currywurst
wirklich aus Berlin kommt.
Ich glaube, man muss hier
eine Currywurst essen,
wenn man Currywurst
einigermassen mag.
Yves?
- Hier!
Nein, nein. Alles gut.
- Entschuldigung.
I'm your helper.
- Ah, super!
Yves?  - Ja?
- Hier.
Did you ordered already? - Ja,
wir haben schon alles bestellt.
Wo ist euer ...
Ah, euer Essen steht schon da.
Langsam! Drei Schritte noch.
Stopp! - Okay. - Die Hand
ausstrecken, hier ist der Tisch.
Super, vielen Dank!
Yves?
- Ja.
Warte!
Hier ist die Gabel.
- Danke schön.
Hier endet der Teller. Die Wurst
ist vorne, die Pommes sind hinten.
Okay, super. Vielen Dank!
- Schönen Tag noch!
Tschüss.
- Tschüss.
Guten Appetit!
- Guten Appetit!
Ich probiere mal. - Ich glaube,
bei dir ist noch jemand.
Ehrlich gesagt, war die Currywurst
nicht so speziell. Irgendwie.
Ketchup, Curry und eine Wurst.
Ich mag eine normale Bratwurst
mit Pommes frites ebenso.
Das schmeckt genau so gut
wie die Currywurst.
Oh, es ist auf der Zwei,
300 m auf der Zwei.
60 m auf der Zwölf.
Sicher haben schon viele
Google Maps gebraucht.
Mit der Karte selbst
können wir nicht viel anfangen.
Wir lassen uns wirklich
durch die Sprache navigieren,
z.B. "nach 200 m rechts abbiegen".
Dank den Apps werden wir
ein stückweit unabhängiger.
* Klacken des Blindenstocks *
Hier hat Helene mal gesungen.
Du meinst,
als die Weltmeister kamen. - Genau.
* Undefinierbare Durchsage *
- Oh, was das wohl ist?
Was ist das?
- Ich weiss es nicht.
* Unverständliche Worte *
Machen Sie irgendetwas frei.
* Unverständliche
Lautsprecherdurchsage *
Im ersten Moment
war es mir etwas mulmig.
Wir wussten nicht,
was wir machen sollten.
Die Durchsage ist zweimal gekommen.
Dann ist ein Fahrzeug
vorbeigefahren.
Es war ein Transport
von irgendetwas,
aber es war
nicht unbedingt gefährlich,
sonst hätte man es den Menschen
sicher angemerkt.
Im ersten Moment war es schwierig,
das Ganze einzuordnen.
* Lockere Musik *
Hier ist es ähnlich
wie beim Zytglogge.
Also, jetzt - drücken!
So?
- Ja, es ist gut.
Stopp!
Was das wohl ist?
Ich weiss es auch noch nicht.
Hat es hier ein Lichtsignal?
Sie laufen.
Ich glaube, wir können laufen.
* Brummen *
Ein Helikopter.
Ich vermute,
es ist gleich dort links.
Es soll ja recht gross sein.
- Ja.
Es muss wie ein Feld sein, oder?
Es heisst, noch 90 m,
aber ich glaube, es ist hier links.
(Beide) Wir probieren es.
Ah, ja. Schau!
- Ah, ja.
Da sind schon die Pflöcke.
Beim Holocaust-Mahnmal
kann man ein Teil davon sein.
Man kann hineingehen,
es ist eine Art Labyrinth.
Es ist spannend, es zu entdecken
und die Grösse zu erfassen.
* Räuspern *
Es macht nicht viel,
sie werden etwas höher.
Beinahe wie Häuser.
Hier wird es auch wieder höher.
- Ja.
Kommst du noch hinauf?
- Nur mit dem Stock.
Ich gehe einfach geradeaus.
- Also, gut.
* Klacken des Blindenstocks *
* Sanfte, leicht wehmütige Musik *
Jonas?
Herr Jonas?
* Sanfte Musik, dumpfe Schläge *
Jonas?
Hier!
Hier, hier, hier.
Ah.
Da. - Wo?
- Da.
Ich bin stehengeblieben,
sonst finden wir uns nie mehr.
Komm!
- Wohin?
Da rein.
Nur schon die Grösse
und die weite Fläche.
Ich finde es wichtig,
dass sie so viel Platz einnimmt.
Wenn man da drin ist und sich
überlegt, wem das gewidmet ist.
Es passt einfach sehr gut.
Das Ganze
hat einen symbolischen Charakter.
Es ist etwas,
das sicher den Erwachsenen hilft,
nachzudenken.
Wir haben gesehen,
dass auch Kinder dort waren.
Die Atmosphäre ist sehr speziell.
Schon krass,
wenn man so darüber schaut -
das Wenige, das ich sehe.
* Beschwingte Musik *
* Ansage am Bahnhof *
Yves?
- Ja.
Hier sollte gut sein.
- Hier wäre gut.
Nehmen wir sie?
- Also, rein!
Ist gut?
- Ich hoffe es.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
dass es der gleiche Zug-
oder Motorenhersteller ist,
wie bei den einen RBS-Zügen.
Die Ausgabe hier
ist aber einfach viel stärker.
(Durchsage) Nächste Station,
Ausstieg links.
Wir lassen die Leute gehen.
Nicht zu lange warten.
Gehen wir? - Ja.
- Da hat es noch einen Pfosten.
Hast du dich beim Pfosten
entschuldigt? - Nein, bei dir.
Es ist schön hier.
Idyllisch.
Zwischen den Bäumen.
Es wirkt nicht
wie ein Touristen-Hotspot.
Wo muss man durch?
- Vielleicht ist geschlossen.
Links geht es nicht. - Eher rechts?
- Da.
Ist das der Modellpark?
(Mann) Das ist der Modellpark,
herzlich willkommen.
Das kostet pro Person drei Euro.
Es gibt zwei schöne Karten dazu.
Ah, super.
- Warte, ich bezahle!
Du kennst das Geld nicht so.
- Hey!
Das sind fünf, oder?
- Das sind zehn.
Siehst du!
- Das passt.
Die Karten.
Waren Sie schon einmal bei uns?
- Nein.
Wäre es möglich, dass eine Person
uns ein oder zwei Gebäude zeigt,
die wir auch anfassen können?
- Aber gerne, natürlich!
Der Modellpark
bietet uns die Möglichkeit,
die Gebäude und Sehenswürdigkeiten
zu ertasten.
Die Gebäude sind so gross,
dass man nur einen kleinen Teil
der Mauern ertasten kann,
so wie z.B. beim Reichstag.
Es ist cool,
wenn man eine Übersicht bekommt
und das ganze Gebäude erfassen kann.
Es ist wie ein Wohnblock.
- Ja, genau.
So, dann schreiten wir nun
auf das Brandenburger Tor zu,
mit der Quadriga, den Säulen
sowie den beiden Nebengebäuden.
Dahinter ist der Streitwagen
mit der Göttin
und dem Adler als Siegeszeichen.
Ja, die Flügel.
- Genau.
Es ist spannend. Ich habe erwartet,
dass das Brandenburger Tor
sehr gross und etwas pompös ist.
Ich bin fast ein wenig enttäuscht.
Wenn im Vergleich dazu
die anderen Gebäude spüren kann,
ist das Brandenburger Tor
ein Nichts.
Das ist ein grosses Gebäude.
- Das ist der Reichstag. - Aha.
Da haben wir ihn wieder.
- Genau.
Da stehen wir auf der grossen Wiese.
Genau, da stehen wir.
Wir schauen direkt von vorne
auf den Reichstag.
Der Korrespondent des Schweizer
Fernsehens hat uns gesagt,
dass Frau Merkel durch dieses Portal
ein und aus gehe. - Ach? Okay.
Aber da hat es eine Treppe,
die ist jetzt nicht ...
Links daneben?
- Oder war das da?
Spürst du sie?
Hier.
- Evtl. springt Frau Merkel da raus.
* Lachen *
Cool ist, wie ... Die Mauer
wurde schön nachgebildet.
Die konnten wir spüren.
Da spürt man so etwas
wie Steinbilder oder Steinplatten.
Die kann man hier
auch sehr gut spüren. - Ja, genau.
Die Verknüpfung von dem,
was Adrian gesagt hat und dem,
was wir erlebt haben ...
Adrian sagte, oben am Eingang
heisse es "Dem Deutschen Volke".
Dass man das nachher wirklich
auch spüren kann, das war cool.
Die Schrift ist schön, geschwungen.
... tschem Volke.
* Bedächtige Klaviermusik,
sanftes Stimmengewirr *
Das ist wahnsinnig. Ja, ja.
Hier ist nun Schluss.
- Das ist wahnsinnig.
* Bedächtige Klaviermusik *
* Bedächtige Klaviermusik gemischt
mit sanften Gitarrenklängen *
Wir biegen hier ab.
Am Anfang dachten wir,
er würde uns überall entlangführen,
weil das Fernsehen dabei war.
Das Fernsehen stellte die Kameras
aber irgendwann ab
und er lief mit uns weiter
und zeigte uns zig Gebäude.
Er hat sich unglaublich viel Zeit
für uns genommen. Es war sehr cool.
Da hat es eine sehr bunte Wand.
Das waren Berliner Skater Boys.
Warte, warte, warte! Du bist
auf der Strasse. - Tramschiene.
Da kann man drücken.
* Autohupe *
Hast du gedrückt?
- Ja.
* Piepsen *
Ich glaube, es ist nicht mehr grün.
Nein, aber es laufen noch Leute
vor uns.
Links hat es wieder Graffiti.
Es kann auch sein, dass es jetzt
schon ist ... - Die Mauer?
Es ist ein längerer Abschnitt.
Wir wollten zur East Side Gallery
weil wir wussten,
dass dort noch
ein Teil der Mauer steht.
Wir wollten auch spüren,
wo die Mauer genau war
und wie hoch sie ist.
Wenn du mit dem Stock
nach oben fährst,
dann kommt oben irgendetwas.
Ich kann es nicht richtig erklären.
Es ist wie ein Stoff oder so etwas.
- Stoff?
Oben ist ...
- Ah, Holz!
Wir könnten uns als Mauerreiniger
bewerben. - Genau.
Siehst du etwas von den Bildern?
Die Bilder kann ich nicht erkennen,
aber ich sehe die Farben.
Reich mir mal deine Hand!
Da ist gelb.
Noch weiter unten ist weiss.
Da ist weiss. Ein gelber Streifen,
ein blauer Streifen. Gelb, gelb ...
Ich habe noch eine Vorstellung
von Farben. Ich kann mich erinnern.
Bis ich sechs Jahre alt war,
habe ich gesehen.
Unter blau, gelb, rot oder so
kann ich mir noch etwas vorstellen.
Als Kind sieht man die Welt
auch noch etwas anders.
Daher kann ich nicht sagen,
wie gut ich es mir vorstellen kann.
Ich habe für mich ein Bild
und das ist das Wichtigste.
Z.T. sehe ich sogar Licht.
Oder wenn die Sonne scheint habe ich
das Gefühl, dass es heller wird.
Aber das ist vermutlich Einbildung.
Wenn ich Wärme auf der Haut spüre,
muss es wohl die Sonne sein.
Ähm, ja ...
Von daher habe ich wohl das Gefühl,
dass es hell ist -
oder dass es heller sein müsste.
Da ist etwas geschrieben.
(Langsam) Ein Mahn....
Hallo?
Ich bin Günter Schäfer.
Guten Tag. - Ich bin der Autor
dieses Bildes. - Ah, okay.
Ich lese den Text vor.
- Ja.
"Diese Flagge
basiert auf dem Grundgedanken
von Frieden und Einheit
aller Völker."
"Sie ist eine Auseinandersetzung
mit dem Erbe
aller deutschen Generationen
nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg."
"Ein Mahnmal
gegen jede faschistische Tendenz."
"Doppelpunkt: Reichskristallnacht,
9. November 1938."
"Mauerfall: 9. November 1989."
Ah!
Das dunkelste Datum.
Die Kristallnacht.
Und das zweite Datum:
Die Mauer öffnet.
Wann haben Sie das gemacht?
- Im März 1990.
Kommen Sie noch häufig vorbei?
Ab und zu. Der Inhalt des Bildes
gefällt nicht jedem.
Es wird sehr oft heftig zerstört.
Bis dato habe ich es
62-mal restauriert.
Es war ein grosser Zufall, dass wir
Herrn Schäfer getroffen haben.
V.a. war es auch schön,
wie er es vorgelesen hat
und uns das Bild erklärt hat.
Das war das Beste daran.
Nichts gegen deine Erklärungskünste,
aber es war schon etwas besser.
- Ich lese dir nie mehr etwas vor.
Vielen Dank.
- Ich bedanke mich.
Alles Gute!
Es war eine schöne Begegnung.
Das fand ich auch. - Und v.a.
sehr wertvoll, sehr informativ.
Einen schönen Tag!
* Lockere Musik,
Klacken des Blindenstocks *
Jetzt können wir noch 1,3 km laufen.
- Ja.
Hallo!
Wir möchten zum Olympiastadion.
Follow me!
Woher kennt er uns?
* Sie lachen. *
Super!
Ist er wohl mit dem Rollstuhl ...
Womit sind Sie unterwegs?
Bike, little Bike.
- Ah!
Gepäck weiss ich nicht,
was es heisst.
Ich glaube, der Grund, warum die
Leute mit uns Englisch sprechen ist,
weil wir
wie die grössten Touristen aussehen.
Sie können mit uns Deutsch sprechen.
Super! Woher kommt ihr?
- Aus der Schweiz.
Da seid ihr.
Schön euch kennenzulernen.
Ich bringe euch noch auf
den richtigen Weg dahin. - Danke.
Viel Spass noch! - Sind wir hier
bei den Olympiaringen?
Ihr seid genau unter den Ringen.
- Okay, super.
Vielen Dank. Einen schönen Tag!
- Tschüss, tschau, tschau!
Super!
Keine Ahnung. Soll ich ihn anrufen?
Ich bin hier.
Ich habe mich angeschlichen.
Ah, hallo!
- Hallo!
Entschuldigung! Wie geht's?
- Gut, danke.
Hallo! Ich bin Jonas. Freut mich.
- Freut mich.
Für mich ist Fussball schon
seit meiner Kindheit extrem wichtig.
Wir haben nachher gemerkt,
dass bei Berlin auch
ein Schweizer Fussballer spielt.
Er spielt bei BSC Hertha Berlin
und heisst Fabian Lustenberger.
Und tatsächlich hat es geklappt
und wir waren plötzlich
per WhatsApp mit ihm in Kontakt.
Was ist?
- Bravo! - Vielen Dank.
Damit man auch weiss,
wer das organisiert hat.
Wie hast du als Schweizer
die Berliner erlebt?
Wir hatten in den ersten Tagen
das Gefühl: Ui, ui, ui!
Gewöhnungsbedürftig.
Sie sind sehr direkt
Hallo, guten Morgen
und Tschüss wird gesagt.
Auf eine Art sehr direkt,
auf die andere sind sie
doch etwas distanziert.
Sie ticken etwas anders.
Für mich persönlich ist es
eigentlich immer gut gegangen.
Ich fand Fabian sehr unkompliziert,
auch herzlich.
Er hat uns geführt und hatte
überhaupt keine Berührungsängste.
Jetzt gehen wir zum Trainingsplatz.
Jetzt geht es leicht hinauf.
- Ich habe das sehr geschätzt.
Es war eine Begegnung auf Augenhöhe,
würde ich sagen.
Spielt ihr auch Fussball?
Eben leider nicht.
Wenn ich sehen könnte,
dann würde ich als Erstes Auto
fahren und Fussball spielen.
Ich wohne in einem Dorf
mit ca. 2'000 Einwohnern.
Und 3'000 davon spielen Fussball.
Ah, sehr gut.
Oh, links unten!
Aber richtig gut links unten.
Keine Chance für den Goalie.
Aber jetzt machen wir es
schwieriger: blind. - Gute Idee.
Hast du mir das Teil?
- Ja.
Wo habe ich meine Tasche hingelegt?
- Ich gebe sie dir.
Danke.
Die Augen schliessen reicht nicht
aus? - Nein, nicht mogeln.
Ich glaube, das Goal ist hier.
Wo? - Hier.
Äh, ich glaube nicht ganz.
Ich glaube, so,
aber ich bin nicht sicher.
Ich versuche es einfach.
Fabian!
Du kannst schauen!
- Ja, er ist drin.
Willst du mal versuchen? - Das wäre
doch etwas für das Training.
Macht ihr das?
Wir haben das
vor ein paar Jahren einmal gemacht.
Einer hatte die Klappe an
und einer nicht,
er hat ein wenig geführt.
Man kann schon sagen, dass das ein
Fussballplatz wie jeder andere ist.
Natürlich, aber weil wir
mit der Person sprechen konnten,
wie sie funktionierte, wie sie
tickt, bekommt man ein anderes Bild.
Tschüss, Fabian!
- Nimmst du den Ball mit? - Ja.
Alles klar. Macht es gut!
Danke gleichfalls.
- Tschüss zusammen!
Er ist sehr sympathisch.
- Ja.
Sehr, sehr, sehr.
Mega cool,
wie er uns alles gezeigt hat. - Ja.
Aber Fussballer
werden wir wahrscheinlich nicht.
* Sanfte Musik *
Wo wollt ihr denn hin?
Wir wollen ...
Wie heisst die Adresse?
Hier links rein,
dann kommt ihr in den Hof.
Super, vielen Dank.
Schönen Tag. Tschüss!
Hier hat es Tische.
Links.
Hast du noch Angaben?
Tag.
- Guten Tag.
Ich begrüsse Sie.
Ich stehe vor Ihnen.
Guten Tag, hallo!
Herzlich Willkommen im Museum
Blindenwerkstatt Otto Weidt.
Otto Weidt
hat hier an diesem Ort 1940
Blinde und Gehörlose
jüdische Menschen unterstützt.
Er versuchte sie zu retten,
er hat sie versteckt.
Er hat sie hier
behandelt wie Menschen.
Wir haben
von diesem Otto Weidt Museum gehört.
Das wollten wir uns
unbedingt ansehen.
Das hat natürlich
auch mit uns selber zu tun,
weil es in dieser Zeit
auch uns betroffen hätte.
Das sind die Werkräume,
in denen eben
die blinden und gehörlosen
Arbeiterinnen und Arbeiter ...
Hier muss man
Besen hergestellt haben. - Okay.
* Beschauliche Klänge *
Wenn wir von Blinden sprechen,
dann sprechen wir
von Blinden aller Religionen.
Es gab schlimmere Repressalien
gegenüber Blinden,
egal ob jüdisch oder nicht jüdisch,
von Sterilisation usw.
Aber solange sie eben noch für
den Staat produktiv sein konnten,
solange konnten sie
sozusagen leben.
Also Zwangssterilisation finde ich
schon grundsätzlich schlimm.
Aber ich kam gar nicht auf den
Gedanken, warum man das gemacht hat.
Als uns nachher die Frau sagte,
dass sie das damals v.a. machten,
weil sie davon ausgegangen sind,
dass Blindheit oder
Sehbehinderung eine Pest sei.
Oder wie haben sie gesagt,
eine Krankheit.
Das hat mich recht mitgenommen.
Es ist eine heftige Vorstellung
zu wissen,
dass man nie eine Familie
haben darf und kann.
Wir wollen sicher viel, sei es
die Möglichkeit auf einen Job
und eine gute Freizeit.
Wir wollen zusammen reisen.
Aber was gibt es wertvolleres
als eine Familie?
Mein Arm ist auf der linken Seite.
Otto Weidt war ja selber
sehr stark sehbehindert oder blind.
Er hat sehr viel bewirkt.
Er konnte auch sehr viel machen.
Ähm ...
Eben trotz seiner Behinderung.
Das zeigt mir,
dass man sich manchmal
einfach für andere Leute
einsetzen muss.
Das ist unglaublich wichtig.
Wo bist du?
- Hier.
Hier spielt jemand Musik.
* Melancholische Musik *
Diese Musik passt zur Stimmung
am letzten Abend.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
ich habe Berlin wirklich von seinen
verschiedenen Seiten kennengelernt.
Mir ist Berlin nun nicht mehr nur
als graue Stadt in Erinnerung,
sondern mit dieser Landschaft ...
Es war cool,
das mit Jonas erleben zu dürfen.
Die Mauer,
die ich extrem in Erinnerung habe,
das Treffen mit dem Künstler.
Das hat die ganze Geschichte
mir noch einmal näher gebracht.
Es hat mir mehr gegeben
als ich erwartet habe.
Das zeigt, dass Berlin eine Stadt
ist, die man mehrmals besuchen kann
und trotzdem
noch nicht alles gesehen hat.
Es reizt mich,
bald wieder hierherzukommen.
Okay. So you can put it
on your head afterwards.
Es ist viel los, hier in Jerusalem.
Wie wir es schaffen, hier
trotzdem den Durchblick zu behalten,
seht ihr nächste Woche.